PETE:  UNEMPLOYMENT HIT A RECORD
HIGH, 14.7% WITH MORE THAN
20 MILLION JOBS LOST IN APRIL.
IT’S A HIT THE COUNTRY EXPECTED
OF COURSE AND ON "FOX & FRIENDS"
YESTERDAY PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
HE’S OPTIMISTIC WE WILL BOUNCE
BACK QUICKLY.
>> WE HAD THE STRONGEST ECONOMY
IN THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD, THE
STRONGEST ECONOMY WE’VE EVER HAD
AND WE HAD TO CLOSE IT WHICH IS
ARTIFICIAL.
WE RECALL FIRMLY CLOSED IT --
ARTIFICIALLY CLOSED IT.
THOSE JOBS WILL ALL BE BACK AND
THEY’LL BE BACK VERY SOON AND
NEXT YEAR WE’LL HAVE A FEN
PHENOMENAL YEAR.
PETE:  WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS
TO JUMP START THE ECONOMY.
JOINING US NOW, THE CHAIR OF THE
PRESIDENT’S REVITALIZATION
COUNCIL, HUD SECRETARY DR. BEN
CARSON.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING ON THE PROGRAM.
>> ALWAYS A PLEASURE.
PETE:  ABSOLUTELY.
FRIEND OF THE SHOW.
YOU HAVE A BIG JOB ON YOUR
HANDS.
YOU HAD A MEETING YESTERDAY
ABOUT IT.
WHAT IS TOP OF MIND FOR YOU AS
YOU TACKLE THIS TASK OF
REVITALIZING OUR ECONOMIC
ENGINE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THINK IT’S
VERY IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS ECONOMIC CRISIS THAT WE’RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW WAS
INTENTIONAL AND IT WAS ON THE
BACK OF AN EXTRAORDINARILY
STRONG ECONOMY.
PETE:  YES.
>> IN 2008, IT WAS JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
WE HAD A VERY WEAK ECONOMY.
SO THIS IS A DIFFERENT SITUATION
ALL TOGETHER.
AND IT’S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
NOT ALLOW THAT ECONOMIC
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE DESTROYED
SO THAT WE CAN RAPIDLY GET BACK
ON THAT TRAIN AGAIN.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT WE PRESERVE,
PARTICULARLY THE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THE SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF THE ECONOMY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY EMPLOY THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS.
AND THE LONGER WE STAY
SHUTTERED, THE MORE OF THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES WILL DIE.
SO ON THE FOREFRONT OF WHAT
WE’RE THINKING ABOUT IS HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE PRESERVE
THE VIABILITY OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND A LOT OF THAT HAS
TO DO WITH USING OUR BRAINS
INTELLIGENTLY, NOT ALLOWING THIS
VIRUS TO COMPLETELY DOMINATE US,
BUT IN FACT HOW DO WE CONTROL IT
AND LIVE WITH IT UNTIL WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COMPLETELY
ELIMINATE IT.
IF WE WAIT UNTIL IT’S ALL GONE,
B WEDEFINITE WE COME OUT, -- BEF
WE COME OUT, OUR ECONOMY WILL BE
GONE ALSO.
PETE:  THE PRESIDENT LAID OUT
GUIDELINES.
WE HAVE SEEN PROTESTS ACROSS THE
UNIONCOUNTRY.
A LOT OF GOVERNORS ARE TAKING IT
SLOW.
HOW CAN YOU INCENTIVEIZE
GOVERNORS TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
RERESPONSIBLEY REOPEN WHO ARE
READY TO DO SO?
THEIR LIVELIHOODS ARE AT STAKE.
THEY DON’T WANT A BAILOUT.
THEY WANT TO REOPEN THEIR DOORS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY CAN.
TARGET’S WIDE OPEN.
MY SMALL RETAILERS ISN’T.
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENS?
>> WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
EMPHASIZE DATA AND EVIDENCE.
WE HAVE ENOUGH PLACES THAT ARE
OPENING UNDER VARIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE CAN LOOK
AT WHAT HAS HAPPENED THERE,
PARTICULARLY WHEN PEOPLE ARE
WISE ENOUGH TO FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES.
YOU KNOW, MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KEEP YOUR HANDS WASHED, BE
CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT YOU TOUCH,
WEAR A MASK WHERE APPROPRIATE,
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
WHEN WE DO THOSE THINGS, IT IS
IMMINENTLY POSSIBLE TO GO BACK
TO WORK.
YOU KNOW, EXCEPT FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE VERY VULNERABLE, THE
ELDERLY PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT UNDERLYING PROBLEMS
THAT COULD INTERFERE WITH THEIR
IMMUNE RESPONSE.
OBVIOUSLY, THOSE PEOPLE WE NEED
TO PROTECT AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE AROUND THEM
UNDERSTAND THE PRINCIPLES.
BUT WHEN THAT’S THE CASE,
THERE’S ABSOLUTELY NO REASON
THAT WE CAN’T GO BACK AND
GOVERNORS LIKE ANYBODY ELSE
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
DATA WHEN IT’S PRESENTED.
PETE:  ABSOLUTELY.
THAT IS COMMON SENSE.
THAT IS TRUSTING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT’S LETTING PEOPLE MAKE THEIR
OWN RISK CALCULATIONS.
DOCTOR, I WISH YOU ALL THE BEST.
YOU HAVE A HUGE JOB WITH MASSIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR OUR COUNTRY.
YOU’VE GOT THE MEDICAL
BACKGROUND AS WELL AS THE
ECONOMIC SIDE.
LAST WORD, REAL QUICK.
>> WE HAVE AN ENORMOUS TEAM,
VIRTUALLY ALL THE AGENCIES AND
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT ARE
INVOLVED, EVERYONE’S
CONTRIBUTING TREMENDOUSLY TO
THIS AND THIS IS AMERICA AND
WE’RE GOING TO GET IT DONE.
PETE:  AMEN.
KEEP THE HEAT ON THOSE
GOVERNORS, A LOT OF THEM
SLOW-ROLLING.